[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce grand débat
la france de demain entre des
classements et renouveau vais vous
soumettre deux citations un plus d'un
glorieux titre le premier peuple de
l'univers c'est ce que charles dickens
disait de la france en 1849 47
la france est une petite chose dont on
ne parle plus c'est gérard depardieu en
il ya fort à parier que les français ont
souvent simultanément ou alternativement
ces deux idées tantôt nous sommes les
meilleurs et avons vocation à l'être
tantôt nous ne valons plus rien et
peut-être pensons-nous d'autant plus que
nous ne voulons plus rien car nous
estimons que notre place véritable et la
première est que dans un monde plus
complexe et plus mondialisé la
compétition pour cette place est rude
alors où est la vérité c'est à cette rue
de questions que nous allons tenter de
répondre lors de ce grand débat pour
cela j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
deux éminents penseurs de notre nation
hubert védrine ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères auteur entre autres
de une vision du monde chez bouquins qui
son dernier livre
vous êtes connu pour votre analyse au
scalpel des enjeux géopolitiques et de
la politique étrangère de la france
et puis arnaud teyssier hauts
fonctionnaires et historien auteur entre
autres avec hervé gaymard de demain la
vème république qui est ici
est paru chez perrin vous êtes un fin
connaisseur de l'histoire politique de
la france et notamment de la vème
république
malheureusement jérôme fourquet qui
devait être présent aujourd'hui a dû
s'excuser
alors pour entrer dans la discussion
j'aimerais commencer par vous poser la
même question à tous les deux celle de
votre avis sur la situation de la france
et en particulier sur l'idée d'un déclin
de notre pays alors monsieur le ministre
j'aimerais commencer par vous car dans
votre ouvrage
on trouve un passage extrêmement juste
sur la france que je vais citer les
français ont bien du mal à trouver un
point d'équilibré en tenant à distance
leurs deux pathologies symétrique aussi
bien la grandiloquence vantard de
bavarder prétentieuse que la nostalgie
l'autodénigrement le doute la repentance
et l'explication voire la haine de soi
et le masochisme vous par les mêmes
termes excellent d'un nombrilisme dans
la déprime
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
que vous entendez par là
et bien je suis embarrassé est ce que
vous avez déjà répondu en fait ce que ma
réponse est précisément que moi je
souhaite que ce pays un jour trouver
l'équilibré
entre la grandiloquence et la dépression
mais j'ajoute deux choses là
les pays européens puis les états unis
les occidentaux ont dominé le monde
pendant trois quatre siècles
bien ou mal et c'est un autre débat et
qui est pas notre débat immédiat la dent
ce qu'elles ont dominé ils n'ont plus le
monopole de cette puissance
depuis assez longtemps parce que les
pays émergents ont émergé c'est plus les
pays en voie de développement sur
lesquelles ont versé des larmes de
crocodile et qui j'ai développé jamais
donc globalement les pays occidentaux
sont en d'exa statistiques on va dire il
faut distinguer le déclin et la
décadence mais le poids des occidentaux
dans le monde actuel n'est pas le même
que il ya deux siècles ou le même que le
poids des américains en 1945 ou même en
1990 et on en fait partie donc on ne
peut pas nier que le poids de la france
soient moindres
puisque le poids des occidentaux dans
leur ensemble et moins grands
sinon il ya plein de choses dans le
monde qui seraient pas ce qu'elles sont
il faut intégrer cette notion c'est un
départ complètement différent de savoir
si on a en plus de ce déclin relatif
statistiques on va dire si on a perdu
notre force d'entrer nergie notre
capacité de régénération et si tard etc
qui a tout le débat sur l'évolution de
la société bon c'est un autre sujet fin
il faut quand même être un peu réaliste
sur le le poids de ce que nous
représentons
politiquement géopolitiquement
démographiquement
mais sans en tirer des conclusions
justement
pessimiste
donc là faut trouver l'équilibré
remercie monsieur tessier alors je vous
pose la même question et j'ajoute une
sous-question dedans puisque vous êtes
historien
je voulais vous demander si vous pensiez
que la défaite de 1940 puis la victoire
de 45 aurait pu jouer un rôle
particulier dans ce mélange de
déploration et de et de fierté
dans l'esprit d'une halle de bol la
dette la victoire de 45 effacer la
défaite de 1940 mais c'est vrai que dans
la conscience collective
avec
sorte de road culpabilité de sentiment
de culpabilité qui marque les années
d'occupation le souvenir de 40 n'a
jamais effacer ça c'est pour l'aspect
historique sur l'aspect déclin plus
globalement marguerite yourcenar des
éclats civilisation était myope qu'elle
ne savait pas où elle en était un être
humain c'est à peu près il connaît le
cycle de la vie c'est à peu près quand
il décline physiquement sinon
intellectuellement une société une
civilisation ne sait pas donc c'est
toujours très difficile de savoir si
nous sommes en déclin mais pour parler
de la vème république tout de suite et
de de gaulle je crois que de gaulle
avait à la fois redouté le déclin ce qui
explique toute sa carrière ce
qu'explique le 17 juin 40 quand il part
en angleterre ce qu'explique 58 ski
truite beaucoup de choses il redoutait
le déclin parce qu'il savait que c'était
une obsession des français que c'était
une menace réelle
il n'acceptait pas le déclin il pensait
que pour conjurer le déclin il fallait
avoir une évaluation réelle de ces
forces et se doter des outils
nécessaires pour peser dans le monde a
raison des réalités bien entendu sans et
imaginer qu'on pouvait revenir
aux
vieilles puissances d'antan qu'il
fallait trouver de nouveaux leviers de
puissance et je crois que c'est toute
l'histoire de la vème république telle
qu'elle a été conçue des institutions de
la vème telles qu'elles ont été imaginés
et des ressorts qu'elle offre au pouvoir
politique quand il sait où quand il veut
s'en servir donc je pense comme hubert
védrine je pense qu'en effet il ya il ya
des causes objectives de perte perte
relative
d'importance de l'europe des pays
européens dont la france qui s'explique
par toutes sortes de facteurs mais parce
que la france profondément est en déclin
se dire est-ce qu'elle a encore une
histoire et c'est encore une histoire à
écrire pour la france une histoire
unitaire j'insiste là dessus puisque
nous sommes dans un une époque un climat
on parle beaucoup de différencier ceux
ci cela
la france si on parle de la france et du
déclin de la france ou de l'avenir de la
france il faut qu'on continue de parler
de la même chose c'est bien un pays qui
est marqué par un projet commun donc
compte tenu de tout cela je crois que
rien n'est jamais perdu et il ya des
ressorts dont il faut savoir user et nos
institutions si elles sont bien utilisés
bien comprise font partie de ces outils
on y viendra
alors on reste un petit peu sur le
terrain de la géopolitique monsieur
védrine déjà je vous lance voulez vous
demander ce que c'était une grande
puissance si la france en était une et
puis si finalement c'était si important
d'être une grande puissance parce que on
peut très bien ne pas être une grande
puissance comme la suisse est bien vivre
et puis on peut être une sorte de
grandes puissances comme la russie enfin
c'est très relatif mais soumettre sa
population à des conditions de vie qui
sont quand même assez mauvaise qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
alors il ya il ya deux questions
factuellement les grandes puissances
la france n'est plus une grande
puissance au change sur louis xiv
napoléon et c'est à dire cécile pas très
bien terminer dans les 2 cas depuis
longtemps les grandes puissances après
la deuxième guerre mondiale puis là
l'élément marquant pour la france et 40
en effet mais c'est pas de l'occupation
c'est 40
la france n'est pas une grande puissance
après 45 même si grâce à churchill l
étau elle est membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité
les grandes puissances et les
superpuissances d'ailleurs froide états
unis une purge donc la création devrait
être dépassé depuis longtemps
mais comme en france on se posait
laquelle est ce qu on est encore une
grande puissance après une des choses
sur le sujet quand on n'est pas une
grande puissance aujourd'hui après la
fin de lurs les états unis en prix
abusivement avoir gagné la bataille de
l'histoire fans d'histoire
hyperpuissance triomphalisme on a gagné
et nos valeurs s'applique partout et le
reste du monde est obligé de suivre bon
en fait non il y avait la chine qui
allait monter derrière donc aujourd'hui
si vous raisonnez grandes puissances
vous allez dire est à julie bien cher
chine bien sûr
les autres ça se discute et si on
raisonne le monde
multipolaire comme aimait le dire
jacques chirac
c'était quelques pays par rapport aux
200 pays et nations unies donc japon
russie quand même
l'un dans se poser la question
brésil ans se pose la question
périodiquement m'enfin ça marche pas et
puis la question européenne que vol les
européens en plus il ya dans les
réflexions française sur ces questions
il ya en permanence l'interrogation est
ce qu'à la fin des fins il y aura une
puissance européenne en tant que telle
dont la france sera une composante on
espère importante mais une composante ou
jamais est ce que les peuples européens
à la fin des fins n'accepteront jamais
de devenir une vraie fédération ça ça
pèse un peu sur toutes les
interrogations est la réponse qu'on
donne à sept longueurs
interrogations dans le long terme change
un peu de réflexion d'aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui mois
je dirais que la france est une
puissance moyenne d' influence mondiale
y en a pas beaucoup les puissances dans
le monde y en a une quinzaine donc c'est
déjà énorme d'être une puissance et ça
ça devrait permette de surmonter le le
balancement entre la grandiloquence et
la dépression l'
influence mondiale quand même pour des
tas de raisons conseil de sécurité
dissuasion nucléaire la langue française
avait atteint donc une des 15 donc ça
devrait être normalement suffisamment le
revigorant pour qu'on envisage l'avenir
avec une certaine confiance son choix
qui a disparu pour le moment mais il
faut bien avoir en tête la distinction
il ya 200 pays aux nations unies à peu
près il ya une quinzaine de puissance au
maximum donc quand giscard à midi
puissance moyenne il s'était fait violer
par tout le monde parce que les gens
avaient retenu moyens
l aimant puissant c'est plus important
alors je me pose la même question
monsieur tessier mais j'ajoute quand
même quelque chose que vous avez parlé
de gaulle il vous connaissait la
citation de de gaulle la france ne peut
être la france sans la grandeur alors
est-ce que la grandeur c'est la
puissance et qu'est ce que peut être la
grandeur sans la puissance
vous avez grandement région de d'évoquer
cette citation parce qu'elle est souvent
mal comprises quand on parle de grandeur
et contre site de gaulle souvent
justement une certaine grandiloquence ou
un mensonge d'état ou une certaine
illusion que de gaulle aurait entretenus
d'ailleurs sur 45 sûr que les ils
rentrent retenu les français dans
l'illusion de la grandeur non quand il
pose de grandeur parle d' aspiration à
une certaine grandeur c'est à dire
d'avoir des buts élevé de gaulle à tout
considérer quand on lit ces écrits des
années 30 tous ces grands écrits comme
le fil de l'épée on voit bien qui il a
un souci majeur qui est la réalité des
rapports de force la réalité des
rapports de puissance il faut alors que
le premier livre de de gaulle qu'il
publie en 24 à 33 ans la discorde chez
l'ennemi c'est un livre qui consacrait à
l'effondrement de l'état allemand 1918
il était fasciné par ça comment un état
s'effondrer du jour au lendemain un état
qu'on croyait extrêmement fort et pas
seulement sur le sous l'effet de la
défaite militaire dont il est convaincu
de la fragilité des civilisations de la
fragilité des états il pense que cette
fragilité doit être combattue par des
institutions solides et par une sorte de
morale collective qui auquel à laquelle
il donne le nom de grandeur donc la
grandeur pour lui si l'aspiration il
faut toujours essayer de voir un peu au
d'avoir des objectifs élevés donc rien
n'est plus faux que de considérer que
chez de gaulle c'est une sorte de
rhétorique creuse et d'ailleurs de
gaulle a été imité souvent et mal sur ce
plan je ne citerai personne je ne parle
pas je ne pense pas au président
mitterrand occurrence mais la rhétorique
un peu creuse de gaulle a été la
rhétorique de de gaulle était utilisée
de manière creuse mais chez lui ce n'est
pas une rhétorique donc je pense que
c'est vraiment cette idée il faut
toujours poursuivre des objectifs une
certaine altitude il faut une grande
ambition en fait quand il parle de
grandeur il parle d'ambition et je crois
que c'est très différent
messieurs les lignes vous vouliez réagir
oui je suis entièrement d'accord et ce
que dit métier mais j'ai pas entièrement
répondu avant à vos deux questions
d'avant et sur la deuxième question les
français sont pas des suisses mais je
suis d'accord on peut être tout à fait
une puissance moyenne ou petite subban
puissant du tonnerre et vivre heureux
vivre heureux parce qu'on a d'autres
objectifs il faut pas voir l'histoire de
france derrière joint les français
entretiennent et dette à la fois
génial et excitante version alexandre
dumas bon et puis pathétique à certains
moments elle est là donc on peut pas la
faire disparaître donc j'en parle
comment on pourrait transformer les
français même s'ils deviennent
étape après étape quand même - j
réaliste moins excité tout ça ils
comprennent mieux l'état réel du monde
ja pas comment on peut les transformer
en suisse donc il ya quand même une
psychologie des des peuples on pourrait
avoir le en norvège voyait il y aurait
pas la même discussion par un pont à
saint dans plein de pays où le niveau 10
est très élevé la qualité de vie
formidable la sécurité formidable donc
ça peut marcher si un système de
sécurité par ailleurs qui vous dispense
de l'effort de sécurité pour soi même
alors chez les schistes c'est la
neutralité qui a fonctionné depuis
quelques siècles on voit pas bien
comment transposer ça à l'échelle de la
france donc l'exemple je suis
sympathique n'est pas une n'a pas livré
solution pour nous
je faisais de cette réflexion parce que
quand je vais très très bien mais quand
on se lève le matin on ne pense pas la
politique extérieure de la france wall
ag une politique on pense plutôt à sa
journée à son travail à ses obligations
donc j'ai toujours un petit peu du mal à
comprendre comment on fait pour les
français ça se traduit est-ce que ça se
traduit dans l'intérêt pour la politique
étrangère pour notre notre puissance
militaire est ce que ça intéresse
vraiment les gens au quotidien
s'est désintéressé énormément parce que
on vit dans une époque elle complètement
sûr informés ou les gens je reçoive des
milliers d'informations dans tous les
sens tout le temps ils connaissent les
événements y compris tragique en temps
réel c'est pas du tout la même chose que
d'apprendre qu'à une catastrophe 3 -
avant dans un pays lointain en temps
réel tant qu'ils sont riches amis dans
une espèce de d'état l'affreux quoi par
le système de la formation permanente
plus les réseaux sociaux etc mais il n'y
a pas de raison que les gens se disent
qu'il raisonne en termes de politique
étrangère il
désire c'est à dire quelle est la
situation réelle
comme on sait quels sont les éléments
dont je dispose les éléments de force et
les mêmes faiblesses mais à tous mes
handicaps
j'ai le choix entre quoi est quoi le
contenu de ce que je suis l'histoire
lointaine la projection à long terme ça
donc j'ai dcid ça pour que quelqu'un de
normal fait ça et un président qui est
payé pour ça un ministre ou sa pensée
leur métier et diplomates mais ça veut
pas dire qu'ils ne s'y intéressent pas
parce que sans arrêt les gens sont
sidérés par telle ou telle information
je te les européens qui ont vécu dans un
monde de bisounours depuis une trentaine
d'années et qui ont rien compris ce qui
se passait dans le monde parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas envie de comprendre donc
qui sont enthousiasmés par des choses
épouvanté par ceux ci frappé choc est
excité passionnait décourager voyez donc
on est devant le domaine des sentiments
et le plein des dirigeants dans la dans
les démocraties modernes c'est
précisément de transformer cette espèce
de masse en fusion qui est très légitime
j'ai un plan psychologique et sur le
plan moral en quelque chose d'un peu
rationnel c'est de plus en plus
difficile le poids des hippies plus le
poète japy dans les grands plus c'est
compliqué de mener des politiques dans
quelque domaine que ce soit d un pote ça
c'est un problème plus large mais on
peut pas en déduire que les gens qui s'y
intéressent pas
justement vous m'amenez où je voulais
aller je voulais qu'on parle de la
france et d'un des inquiétudes qui la
touche aujourd'hui je voulais commencer
par l'idée qu'il y aurait une
fragmentation sociale dans notre pays et
je voulais vous demander monsieur
tessier si vous souscriviez à cette
analyse c'est à dire cette idée que
nous vivrions finalement nous serions
plutôt une association de petites
communautés différentes avec des
intérêts différents et ne nous n'aurions
plus ce sens de l'intérêt général et ça
se traduirait notamment vous en parlez
dans votre livre par
l'abstention
que pensez-vous de 2,7 de cette idée
alors il ya plusieurs aspects dans votre
question fragmentation de la société
c'était très étudiée justement par des
gens comme jérôme fourquet ça correspond
à des évolutions sociologiques qui sont
qui montre que la france est beaucoup
plus complexe on veut pas tout ramener
centre ville banlieue
monde rural urbanité enfin tout cela à
l'urbanisme tout cela est très complexe
c'est vrai et on peut penser qu'à ça
mais j'ai envie de dire que ç'a toujours
été le cas peut-être d'une manière
différente mais la société française a
toujours été multiples on sait ce qu
était la société française avant 1914 et
pourtant avant 1914 c'est quelque chose
qui est oubliée aujourd'hui les
institutions ne n'étais pas très aimé de
la troisième république parce qu'il veut
beaucoup d'instabilité ministériel
c'était un régime qui n'était pas très
considéré et c'était un régime qui
s'étaient une france qui est encore très
rurale et pourtant les gens voter les
gens aient tenté voter énormément il y
avait un taux de participation très
élevé donc je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
faire de parallèle entre eux la
diversité d'une population et et le fait
d'aller voter je pense que l'abstention
aujourd'hui s'explique d'abord par le
fait que beaucoup de français ont le
sentiment que j'ai horreur de ce terme
me levais l'employé parce que pour le
coup il n'est pas totalement erronée que
l'offre politique ne les satisfait pas
ils ont peut-être le sentiment que c'est
toujours un petit peu les mêmes
politiques qu'on leur propose et puis je
crois aussi que
il y a une volonté d'être impliqué
davantage
dans le système de décision alors à cela
il ya deux réponses et ceux qui disent
il faut il faut davantage impliquer le
citoyen de base dans la décision
publique etc c'était un peu le but de la
décentralisation s'est développé les
libertés locales la décentralisation
était développé de manière extrêmement
forte la france est un pays très
décentralisé
aujourd'hui on continue dire qu'il est
centralisé parce que dans notre tête ça
reste quelque chose de très marqués par
l'histoire mais enfin c'est un pays très
décentralisé mais visiblement ça ne
suffit pas alors il ya des il ya des
ressources
lorsque la vème république a été créé en
cinquante huit dans la constitution
l'article 3 10 la souveraineté du peuple
s'exprime par deux voix il s'exprime par
l'élection de ses représentants et par
le référendum et c'est s étaient pas le
fait du général de gaulle c'est tous les
constituants tout ce qui entre et on a
bien vu que le référendum est tombé en
désuétude n'en réclame là aujourd'hui il
référendum d'initiative citoyenne star
mais le référendum tel qu'il est prévu
par la constitution et dont le champ
était très largement étendue en 95 et
très peu utilisé n'est plus utilisée
parce qu'il fait peur aux politiques
parce qu'il est tellement puissant comme
instrument et pourtant c'est un moyen
moi je maintiens que c'est un moyen on
en parle beaucoup dans le livre nous
avons dirigé qu'avec des mains c'est un
moyen d'associer c'est un moyen
démocratie directe qui est prévu par la
constitution et c'est pas du tout le
plébiscite à la napoléon iii les je
voudrais citer un exemple d'un
référendum qui était décisif et qui a
donné lieu à un débat très approfondie
un vrai débat de société bien que le
sujet fut très technique c'était le
débat sur maastricht en 92 dont pourtant
c'est un vrai débat pour faire un
référendum sérieusement on peut
impliquer la société dans les décisions
politiques j'imagine par exemple ce que
ça pourrait donner sur les retraites sur
le système de protection sociale
seulement il faut avoir le courage et
puis c'est vrai que ça implique une
certaine mise en jeu de la
responsabilité politique comme l'a
montré le général de gaulle en 69
puisqu'il est parti sur un référendum
perdu alors que rien ne l'y contraignait
monsieur védrine est ce que vous
partagez cette analyse notamment celle
du référendum
globalement oui
je suis très d'accord avec ça je pense
que les grilles classique d'explication
fonctionne moins bien droites et gauches
du déclassé
sa pas complètement disparu yves en face
ça fonctionne moins bien et je crois
qu'il ya un vrai qu'il va j'entre ceux
qui continuent à croire dans le vote et
qui continue à accepter d'être
représenté la démocratie représentative
et l'ensemble de ceux qui le rejettent
surlonge d'empierrement chance abstenant
et pour moi les démocraties modernes
sont beaucoup plus menacée par sa queue
par poutine
le fait qu'ils aient des gens quand on a
mis une psychologie gilet jaune très au
delà du nombre exact de gilet jaune mais
ça traduit quelque chose de très profond
dans les gens je veux plus être
représenté je suis moi même mon propre
représentant il faut me reconsulter et
6e quelqu'un qu'on a et lui à trois
points 18 ans ma place c'est pas
démocratique c'est la demande de
démocratie directe qui était une
gentille utopie pour des gaines petite
commune en petites paroisses en suisse
soit y ait aujourd'hui vous avez tous à
un engin comme ça
voilà donc on peut vous consultez tous
les matins est ce que vous êtes pour le
rétablissement de la peine de mort ah
oui il ya un crime à 3 6r poc j'en
établi le lendemain et qu'est ce qui m'a
pris je suis tout à fait compte en fait
j'utilise au ficg mans jabot lee
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire des budgets
des hôpitaux je voulais triplé
naturellement toque jeu triple des
budgets mais la france est le pays où
allait au bond ou la fiscalité la plus
lourde cela diminue de moitié et c'est
bon ce qu'était une utopie philosophique
autrefois devient technologiquement
possible et ça peut se combiner avec ce
qu'on appelle le populisme qui peint
terme fourre tout qui fera pas employer
négativement parce que celui-ci des
vrais gens qui sont des citoyens et un
je
pense qu'il ya un vrai problème là et
qu' il faut faire attention à la
mauvaise réponse qui serait de dire on
l'art consulter les gens tout le temps
et moi je suis pas du tout pour les
convention citoyenne
parce que c'est des gens n'ont pas plus
de légitimité que les gens qui vont
voter donc on fait appel à des gens il
ya plus que les militants et qu'ils y
vont en fait donc qui font des
propositions qui évidemment que le corps
électoral dans ce chantier n'aurait
jamais soutenu et après on disait on n'a
pas appliqué les mesures qu'ils ont
demandé tout un donc c'est un cercle
vicieux en revanche je pense comme
monsieur tessier je connais pas je
connaissais pas sa position avant là
dessus donc je découvre là que je suis
d'accord il faut complètement abandonné
la condamnation de principe ou la peur
de principe du référendum qui existait
dans notre république et je pense qu'on
peut y avoir encore plus souvent pas
pour remettre en cause les mandats du
président ou des députés mais sur des
questions à trancher alors on a un
mauvais exemple récent qu'est notre dame
des landes
il ya eu finalement dans des conditions
compliquées à des référendum le
périmètre était discutable ayez la
décision n'a pas été suivie mais moi je
pense que c'est là la bonne réponse
entre des deux points le maintien d'une
démocratie représentative de plus en
plus faible
malgré tout et puis la
démocratie directe et permanente qui
conduit au chaos je crois donc je suis
en fait chaud c'est d'abord
faire l'avocat du diable
parce que finalement la démocratie
directe quand elle fonctionne
normalement donc comme en suisse à
nouveau elle est très différente d'une
forme de plébiscite permanent puisque
elle se fait de façon très encadrée
d'abord il faut que la question qu'on
veut poser soit soumise à un certain
nombre de signatures un pourcentage de
l'électorat et puis ensuite une fois
qu'on a cette question qui est
d'ailleurs juridiquement vérifier elle
est posée à la nation et il ya quand
même une grande différence entre le fait
d'appuyer sur son téléphone oui non oui
non et le fait d'être engagé mais même
par la démocratie directe
oui mais je complète parce que le rique
quand ils existent il vient du bas au
centre où les questions viennent d'un
citoyen ou d'une association alors que
le référendum qui a je suis d'accord
avec vous un excellent outil la vème
république trop peu utilisé trop peu
utilisé par don vient forcément duo est
ce qu'il n'ya pas une grande différence
entre les deux systèmes finalement mais
c'est ici non parce que le référendum
même si n'implique pas nécessairement
comme l'a fait de gaulle la démission
automatique du président la république
suppose un engagement
de l'exécutif légitime simplement c'est
comme ça je crois que on a souvent dit à
l'époque c'étaient des plébiscites de
bol c'est pas vrai c'était sur le
règlement de la guerre d'algérie c'était
sur l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel le
référendum de 69 était très important
pour lui parce qu'il y avait tout un
projet derrière que les gens n'ont pas
compris à l'époque parce qu'il était
assez visionnaire si je peux utiliser ce
terme tout à fait d'actualité ici et ils
s'étaient ça fait fameuse idée sur la
participation sur la façon de prévoir
l'évolution du capitalisme mais c'était
c'était véritablement des sujets de fond
avec des campagnes de fond alors ça
existe il y à des consultations
aujourd'hui des grands débats etc mais
c'est des grands débats qui ne se
terminent pas par un vote or il faut
qu'il y ait un vote parce que comme le
disait hubert védrine sinon c'est celle
la démocratie de l'instant c'est à dire
la non démocratie donc c'est quelque
chose de tout c'est pas tout à fait le
référendum suisse c'est vrai que c'est
très politique mais en même temps ça
peut être la faculté pour le pouvoir en
place de se re légitimer dans de grandes
entreprises je pense à l'usagé du
référendum prénom pour des sujets de
société majeur le système de protection
sociale la nature du régime de retraite
et qu'on ne nous dise pas c'est trop
compliqué pour les citoyens et qu'ils
voteront pour ou contre le pouvoir
maastricht dieu sait que c'était un
traité compliqué et quand philippe
séguin a pris son bâton de pèlerin et a
fait le tour de france pendant des mois
il expliqué aux gens les enjeux derrière
maastricht et des gens ont voté et en
définitive le oui de remporter mais je
dirais que le oui l'a emporté en toute
connaissance de cause parce que les gens
ont compris qu'elles étaient les enjeux
les risques et aussi des éventuelles
avancées que ça pouvait comporter donc
c'est un vrai il ya quelque chose qui
m'a beaucoup frappé c'est ce que dit de
gaulle quand il quitte le pouvoir il est
temps en irlande c'est vrai j'en irlande
il a quitté le pouvoir et reçoit son
secrétaire général de l'elysée bernard
tricot il lui dit vous savez
peut-être que je n'ai pas fait que j'ai
peut-être commis des erreurs mais une
chose dont je suis certain c'est que
j'ai laissé à la france des institutions
des outils et récité le référendum le
parlementarisme rationnalisé des outils
avec lesquels on peut gouverner si on le
veut et il insistait de thil il dit avec
ces outils on peut gouverner il ajouté
si on le veut si on prend le risque
politique aussi
alors comment comment peut-on expliquer
que ça ne se soit pas passé exactement
comme ça parce que dans l'exemple des
derniers référendum notamment un celui
de 2005 nous montre que par exemple ce
principe de responsabilité qui consiste
à démissionner ainsi et bien le
référendum n'est pas acceptée n'existent
plus donc hyper v day ne sais pas ce que
vous en pensez est ce que ça voudrait
dire qu'un président de la république
devrait
démissionner quand un référendum est
perdu est ce que ça devrait dire
qu'il eu autre chose qui n'est pas
mentionnée mais qui est dans votre livre
que il devrait laisser le parlement la
vie parlementaire existait beaucoup plus
comment vous voyez les choses
je vais juste et c'est là c'est le
problème n'était pas de savoir s'il
présidant la rigueur démissionner ou pas
parce que je crois qu'il était entendu
qu'ils ne le feraient pas ce n'est pas
une obligation mais ce qui était
reproché au référendum c'est que s'est
conclu ces résultats n'ont pas été
suivis mais je vois là en fait sien j'en
ai même pas parlé parce qu'on en a c'est
devenu un lieu commun bien sûr le
premier problème du référendum de 2005
c'est qu'ensuite il est revenu par la
petite porte en 2008 par le par le
congrès mais je la joute un autre
problème qui est que ça marcherait
beaucoup mieux aussi le président
démissionner en cas de référendum
rejetée non moi je suis pas d'accord
avec ça je pense que dans certains cas
très particulier si le président
s'engage en jeans beaucoup continuent à
mission que si tout le monde est
d'accord sur cette orientation cette
grande réforme ok on peut décider on
peut imaginer ça mais je reviens plus
tôt à notre réponse d'avant moi je suis
favorable à un élargissement
disons relatifs des possibilités du
recours elle un nom pour trancher des
questions de société par exemple mais
qui n'engage pas du tout la démission du
président voilà on revient au plébiscite
déguisés comme j pas pour ça il peut y
avoir des cas mais dans les autres cas
il faut combiner les les demandes
déchets qui rebondit pas vous l'avez
rappelé en suisse où des sujets qui
peuvent être proposées par le priant de
gouvernement dans des quelque sept
chaînes pas tous les matins à 7
viendrait ridicule comme l'idée c'est
plutôt des dijon de contrebalancer la
l'exigence frénétique de démocratie
directe permanente mais hank pas
complètement il faut le l'équilibré de
façon raisonnable donc je suis plutôt
pour des d'autres sujets qui n'engage
pas automatiquement la région et du
président sans l'écarter complètement
celle ci entre les deux il faudrait voir
si ça en quelques années si ça calme
appelant fébrilité
démocratique anti démocratique de nos
sociétés
comment expliquez vous alors que les
précédents présidents la république est
très peu utilisé cet outil de cette
façon peut-être monsieur tessier pour
commencer je crois que c'est parce
qu'ils ont peur de la réponse est là je
crois que le référendum de 2005 de ce
point vue de la été
une démonstration de cela ils ont peur
de réponse c'est vrai qu'il faut jouer
le jeu sur une demande ou au peuple
souverain ce qu'il veut il faut il faut
suivre sa décision sinon c'est pas la
peine de faire de référendum donc il ya
ça et puis je crois comme la peur oui du
d'un engagement plus ou moins larvée de
la responsabilité du président parce
qu'il ya le précédente de gaulle qui
écrase tout le monde de gaulle quitté en
avec des sondages de popularité très
élevée quand il est parti il qui
d'ailleurs a perdu le référendum d'assez
peu en réalité compte tenu de son âge
des circonstances il ya ce précédent un
peu écrasant donc c'est une arme qui
fait peur mais on oublie toujours que
c'est vrai que c'est un outil
constitutionnelle risquaient mais la
force de cet outil est à due proportion
du risque qu'il comporte quand on veut
gouverner et avancer sur des sujets de
société majeur mais rien encore une fois
je reprends l'exemple de maastricht
françois mitterrand n'a jamais dit qu'il
démissionnerait s'il paie daïra d'el
référendum sur maastricht pourtant il
s'est engagé et j'ai toutes sortes de
raisons de penser que l'engagement
personnel de françois mitterrand a fait
basculer un électorat très hésitant du
côté du oui donc je vois pas où est le
problème je crois que c'est plutôt que
les générations politiques qui s'ensuit
qui ont suivi ont peut-être on était
plus frileuses et ont peut-être oublié
un peu l'esprit des institutions de
gaulle savait qu'elle était la portée du
référendum françois mitterrand pour
arrêter l'adversaire de 2 go le début de
la 5ème république
savait aussi qu'elle était la force du
référendum donc je crois qu'il ya sera
une question de culture politique
messier védrine vouliez répandre moi je
redis je suis pour déconnecter les deux
mais je ne sais pas si mitterrand aurait
pu rester en fait si le maastricht le
non l'avait emporté
peut-être que oui peut-être qu'il aurait
précisément clarifier la doctrine disant
vous avez tranché meilleur sa porte
n'est pas sur le mandat du président
mais moi j'en avais tiré une autre le
change était secrétaire général de
l'elysée à l'époque je m'étais dit c'est
pas le débat institutionnel européen
je le dédie si un sujet comme ça tout
les autorités tous les grands esprits de
ce pays tous les responsables chauffe le
front national de l'époque tout le monde
était pour le oui tout le monde puisse
le poids énorme de mi-temps s'est passé
avec un point d'écart un point d'écart
donc moi j'ai commencé à partir de là à
me dire si on a perdu les peuples en
route ce qui a vraiment un bug dans la
construction européenne et d'ailleurs
quand il ya eu le traité constitutionnel
et le référendum le traité s'imposer pas
le terme prostituées elles étaient
abusifs tout ce qu'on veut il le
référendum s'est également dangereux les
français ont rejeté ce n'était pas une
surprise là mon avis les néerlandais
peuple très ouvert très pro-européens
beaucoup plus que les français ont voté
non encore plus le chancelier schröder
falek changer des fraudeurs que j'avais
revu m'avait dit s'il a vu un référendum
en allemagne ce qui est interdit la
réponse aurait été non
j'ai dit ah bon mais pourquoi
l'allemagne se présente toujours comme
plus pro-européenne que les autres m'a
dit non ça c'est avant la réunification
parce qu'il était assez franc assez cash
et médiers deuxièmement les länder ne
supporte plus le grignotage leurs
compétences par la commission il accorde
justice s'il ya vu un référendum voilà
je m'égare je m'éloigne de vos questions
parce que c'est plus européen
qu'institutionnels et donc moi je suis
pour un recours de temps en temps
référendum sur des questions qui ne met
pas en cause la légitimité du président
et qui peut être tranchée par la société
toute entière il ya quelques cas vous en
avez cités il ya des cas aussi sur les
qu'ils sont et à 2
de bioéthique c'est comme ça mais en
fait à ma question suivante qui était
celle de l'opinion quand il ya ce qu'on
appelle c'est vraiment un cliché une
déconnexion entre l'opinion et leurs
représentants est ce que il n'ya pas un
problème de représentation je sais que
c'est une question est un sujet qui
vraiment rebattu mais on est obligé
quand même de se poser la question et là
je vais proposer enfin je me suis
prononcé un terme que vous trouvez
pélieu monsieur tessier puisque je vais
parler du scrutin proportionnel et vous
dites dans votre livre justement que
c'est une idée très périlleuse qui est
alimentée par la situation actuelle mais
qui ne serait pas une solution même pour
améliorer la représentation pourquoi
parce que leurs représentants ne
représentent pas l'opinion ils
représentent la nation il représente le
pays qui n'est pas seulement la société
à un instant t le dire c'est ça
l'opinion c'est quelque chose qui est
soumis
à l'influencé du temps l'affluence comme
les ibères védrine de tous les les les
relais tous les médias tout tout tout
les toutes ces outils nous avons
aujourd'hui pour être influencé ou pour
crois que nos influences mais le
représentant c'est pour ça qu'il est élu
pour une certaine durée c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que le présidente de prison
la république est élu pour une durée
différente de celle du parlement parce
qu'on considérait que son action
s'inscrivait dans une durée différente
c'est pour ça qu'on a toujours une idée
aussi que l'administration devait
inscrire son action dans une durée
différente de celle du politique la vie
démocratique c'est la conjonction de
durées différentes l'idée tant qu'un
système démocratique ne doit pas être
aux ordres de l'opinion d'un moment de
l'opinion reine du monde parce que
l'opinion est changeant de ce que dit
bert védrine sur la peine de mort est
tout à fait exact donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des mandats qui ont une
certaine durée c'est pour ça que le
président de la république avant avait
un mandat de 7 ans et non de cinq ans
alors il peut arriver qu'il y ait des
mouvements d'opinion
très fort qui montre qu'il ya une
attente de la société ou en tout cas que
des questions doivent être tranchées et
c'est la pardonnez moi de retomber à
nouveau sur mes pieds c'est là que le
référendum trouve son utilité puisque
sans remettre en cause la légitimité des
pouvoirs constitutionnels il permet
quand même aux pouvoirs exécutifs de
vérifier un petit peu sa légitimité sur
certains projets donc en réalité il faut
admettre que la démocratie il ya eu un
très très beau livre d'un spécialiste
des sciences politiques qui s'appelle
yves mény qui s'appelle démocratie
imparfaite il explique la démocratie
elle est imparfaite par nature puisque
elle est fondée sur la souveraineté du
peuple et que dès qu'on organise une
démocratie on commence par frustré le
peuple un peu de cette capacité de
décision direct mais c'est normal parce
que la démocratie ne peut pas
fonctionner comme si on adorera avec le
bras levés donc il faut l'organiser il
faut la structure et il faut mettre des
temporalités il faut mettre des bornes
des lois des règles de façon à ce que la
vie collective soit organisée d'une
manière un peu rationnelle et avec
modération le problème est de trouver le
bon équilibre dans la société
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est ce que ce que
nous disions tout à l'heure trouver le
bon équilibre entre les impulsions de la
société qui peuvent devenir de plus en
plus vigoureuse de plus en plus
instantanée et la nécessité d'une action
démocratique dans le long terme et je
pense pour ça que c'est un peu l'idée du
livre que nous avons dirigé qu'avec des
mâts c'est pour ça que des institutions
de la vème si elle était appliquée
pleinement offre tout ce spectre et ce
n'est pas étonnant puisque elles ont été
conçues en tirant les leçons de 150 ans
d'errance a séduit chalet on avait usé
15 constitution avant d'en arriver là
donc le référendum
la démocratie représentative
exécutif formé en même temps des moyens
de consulter le peuple très souple voilà
c'est cet équilibre là il faudrait
revenir à cet équilibre
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
revenir à 7 cet équilibre parce que vous
êtes optimiste ou
réaliste des deux je pense pas forcément
mais je suis d'accord c'est ça la c'est
ça la ligne
il faut
carbonneau défaut
réfléchir de façon plausible il faut
garder des institutions
suisses qui nous a permis d'affronter
beaucoup de beaucoup d'épreuves
difficiles dans ce pays
je ne faut pas ajouter à la
désorganisation
faut pas ajouter à la confusion des
esprits
il faut faire des adaptations mais pas
non plus capitulé devant l'esprit du
temps
et sur l'opinion
j'aime bien ce qu'elle fait parce que ça
recadre quand même les mécanismes
d'opinion au fait tocqueville avait qui
est un vrai génie au début du xixème
siècle quand même en étudiant le cas
américain il avait dit le problème est
le danger pour les démocraties et avec
un exemple de démocratie c'était les
états unis à l'époque c'est qu'elles
finiront par traiter les questions
extérieures sur la base des
considérations intérieures et encore ils
connaissaient pas les médias ni les
sondages d'une information continue ni
les réseaux sociaux donc un moment donné
le poids de l'opinion est quelque chose
d extrêmement dangereux qui peut faire
sauter tous les verrous tous les verrous
qui peut alimenter des réactions de
totalitaire et le pin on ne peut pas
trancher une question lapinou elle
réagit quand bien au mal elle réagi
seydoux et les binaires et les
manichéenne à l'opinion donc faut bien
qu'ils aient tout un système qui soit
maintenue hassen constitutionnelles
institutionnelles qui fasse une certaine
place bien conçu à des consultations
plus fréquentes il faut garder quelque
chose qui qui refroidissent comme on
dirait en termes d'ingénierie fera 10
c'est pas pour rien des yo ka à
l'origine des démocraties et des
républiques ont allumé des deux chambres
et à la première chambre qui
éventuellement peut réagir comme ça
enfin brücker une nouvelle boîte où les
trois jours sur ses skis et grotesque et
puis le deuxième chambre qui est censé
réfléchir
ils ont détruit jean seyssel mois
dernier mais c'est plus compliqué
donc oui je suis d'accord il faut il
s'assiéra viendrai à bazarder des
institutions complètement et quand on
regarde les protagonistes un sixième
république c'est pas votre formule pas
du tout mais en général quand vous
regardez la 6e tous les plans de 6ème
république qui sont mis en avant
régulièrement ça consiste à affaiblir le
pouvoir exécutif en fait c'est ça l'idée
or il est déjà très affaibli
et dans les démocraties modernes il a
beaucoup de mal à fonctionner c'est pour
ça que par expérience que j'ai passé un
mois au moins 20 ans pas dans la
politique mais dans le pouvoir voudrait
c'est différent j'en ai tiré une très
grande indulgence
et compréhension pour les gens qui
dirigent malgré tout rien donc qui il
faut lutter contre un phénomène terrible
que dans les démocraties a de moins en
moins de leader il ya de plus en plus de
followers
ça c'est dangereux
donc je me retrouve dans vos
propositions
et leurs une dernière question sur sur
les réformes à venir où les changements
que vous préconisez ce qui est autre
chose si à des réformes en particulier
que vous aimeriez voir arriver dans
notre pays je vais poser la question à
tous les deux et on a on n'a pas
beaucoup de temps mais c'est juste pour
avoir une idée
monsieur védrine pour commencer
non j'ai pas de réforme fétiche en
dehors de ce qu'on a évoqué on s'est
retrouvé là dessus je pense est une
question de courage politique
donc
ça veut dire qu'on peut pas de gouverner
dans les démocraties sans aller un peu
contre contre les croyances du moment
qu'ils sont exagérées exacerbée
hystériser éphémère dont j'ai parlé des
feux de cheminée il faut dire aux gens
non ça c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible on peut pas répondre aux
gigantesques demande sociale sociétale
et c'est dans le pays encore une fois à
quai ou la fiscalité la plus lourde au
monde l'autre la dispute est évident ce
terrible comme ça qu'on trouve un
général dans la presse économique sur la
presse économique on peut pas totalement
écrire n'importe quoi rien par rapport
au reste donc à certains moments il faut
quand même renvoyer les citoyens à des
choix pas simplement à des réactions ou
l'expression d'émotions ce qu'ils
peuvent comme ils sont consultés pour
des sondages ils peuvent exprimer les
émotions comme il faut les ramener dans
le processus de décision donc ce n'est
pas une réforme fétiche c'est le cas si
c'est des termes un peu archaïque j'ai
déjà laissé des termes de voix la des ti
et l'enseignement des aides c'est
différent de courage des athéniens
ancien des choses comme ça des romains
un cas unique et tout ce qu'on pourrait
mettre sous le terme de morale et
civique
c'est ça qui fait défaut mais est ce que
c'est possible de dire ça sans être
balayés aussitôt
le système
actuel donc il faut en partie ramer à
contre-courant quand même quel que soit
le sujet de la réforme
par exemple regarder l'éducation c'est
évident qu'un effondrement de la
transmission éducative dans ce pays
il ya une trentaine d'années les fameux
système piasa vos salles et d'évolution
avait mis et avait montré que en
allemagne l'éducation était moins
semprun ses filiales je parle pas des
l'obsession sur les inégalités j'ai
transmission pédagogie qui pourrait donc
des analyses montrant que la
transmission s'affaiblissait que sa main
un poil sont là les allemands avaient
dit bon on va prendre le sujet à bras le
corps et ils ont énormément changé
énormément changé en france qui ont eu
le début des classements de ce genre
casa unanimité en france pour dire les
classes on s'en fiche de penser des
classements inspiré par les américains
pour je sais pas quoi après ses comptes
redoublent donc une sorte d'incapacité
de ce pays à force de démagogie faut
dire les choses simplement de démagogie
à prendre le sujet à bras le corps et on
devient progressivement j'ai pas si on
est en déclin en à la fois de choses et
on com
on devient quand même un des pays
occidentaux qui accumule le plus grand
nombre de problèmes sociaux ou autres
n'ont réglé
ça n'appelle pas une réponse
institutionnelle oui bien
monsieur tessier votre réponse moi j'ai
pas de projet de réforme ni rien je
pense que simplement étant donné parce
qu on oublie vite les sociétés oublie
vite nous sortons nous sortons nous
l'espérons d'une période de deux années
marquées quand même par une situation
totalement hors norme je vous rappelle
quand même que s'il fallait remplir un
papier pour sortir et c'est fait
d'ailleurs notre la démocratie et quand
même fonctionné nous sortons d'une
période hors norme où l'état a porté la
société à bout de bras
et je pense que le moment serait venu
d'essayer de réfléchir après tout cela
après ces événements qui reviendront
sans doute c'est inéluctable par exemple
je vois la décentralisation je disais
qu'on était un pays qui gardait la
mentalité d'un pays centralisé où la
représentation d'un pays centralisé
alors que nous étions un pays
décentralisé je pense que ce serait le
moment de faire une réflexion profonde
sur le rôle de l'état sans agressivité
sans slogans
sur la décentralisation a toujours de
décentraliser davantage on n'a jamais
fait vraiment de bilan de la
décentralisation donc c'est une sorte
d'état des lieux de nos institutions
alors peut-être nos attitudes des
institutions administratives le rôle de
l'etrat ce qui advient ce qui a moins
bien la décentralisation ce qui a marché
ce qui n'a pas marché au lieu d'être
toujours dans une sorte de deux courses
au slogan qui ne permet pas d'aborder
les vrais sujets parce que vraiment
n'oublions pas ce que nous avons vécu
pendant deux ans c'est absolument
incroyable
sur le plan des libertés publiques et
pourtant notre société a tenu elle a
tenu face à une épreuve quand même
extraordinairement graves qui pourraient
encore une fois se reproduire donc je
pense quel moment peut-être de réfléchir
un certain nombre de fondamentaux de
notre organisation publique et de voir
aussi que parfois nous faisons bien les
choses et que nous avons cédé raison
d'avoir confiance en nous je vous
remercie beaucoup
tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
débat passionnant c'est malheureusement
la fin de cette discussion nous allons
passer bientôt au prochain débat sur le
sujet vivent en ville en 2050 merci
merci à tous je me permets de petite
immersion pour sur le grand débat pour
remercier la modératrice
laetitia je trouve ce bonnart excusez
moi si je prononce mal votre nom qui est
donc rédactrice au point que notre
partenaire sur ce salon du livre
rédactrice en charge des pages idées et
des bas et je vous invite si vous le
souhaitez à la retrouver parce qu'elle
même a rédigé et récemment un ouvrage
qui s'appelle de la france ce pays que
l'on croyait connaître coédité par
perrin et les presses de la cité si vous
souhaitez la retrouver à une table
d'hôte heures elle est également attendu
sur l'espace et c'est voilà et merci
messieurs m messieurs pour ce débat
passionnant merci hein
[Musique]